[Music]
you are not afraid to to be naked and
recently you started posting pictures
where you show your I don't show my
boobs anymore I just to show my butt I'm
moving down yeah moving eventually the
ankles let's take a look we have this is
you in the shower now you look fantastic
by the way you're clearly you thank you
I work out all the time
I do yeah I work out I have to you have
to work out all the time if you want to
live a lifestyle like mine if I drink
like I do I have to work out every day
for like two hours it's a nightmare two
hours a day yeah sometimes I play tennis
and then I work out with my trainer are
you doing a specific butt exercise yeah
I do a lot of butt stuff he's good with
butts his name is Ben Bruno I also sleep
with him sometimes it's a casual thing
it's very countable the training he's my
professional trainer about anybody I
implied sleep with a lot of people that
I employ so like if like my tennis
instructor I sometimes sleep with him or
my trainer my landscaper anybody I'm
paying we're renting I want to all the
service place someone yeah someone's
there to read the gas meter and it's
like yeah yeah yeah use use up what I
can use up all right this is a
judgment-free zone you recently Mike
you're judging me I feel a lot of
judgement no no this is envy you with my
landscaper yeah I love that I love that
guy recently you recently said that you
haven't had sex in ten months you talked
about that was a few months ago was a
few months ago yeah okay so what was
going on there was that intentional no
no no I don't want to be celibate I
would I just how could go ten months if
anyone that comes to the house to
perform a service
yeah that makes no sense oh you get it
all you got to do is order something
from Amazon yeah it just was a quick for
the year flew by and all of a sudden I
said to my girlfriend I was like I
haven't I don't think how long has it
been she was yeah how long has it been
I'm starting to get a little creepy and
then it was like 10 months and then I
was like oh my god this is embarrassing
I don't want that on my resume I got to
have sex with somebody so I have a boy
that I have sex with in Barcelona and I
was gonna go visit him to pray about how
if he calls you on the phone is that
caller ID boy in Barcelona I have sex
but I mean do you talk about him like
he's like a guy you're not that familiar
with well they don't get this show
Barcelona right yeah yeah they do no
yeah no I just have sex with him
sometimes when I travel but anyway he
lives so I was gonna break my streak and
go meet him in Barcelona and my friend
said don't you think would be more
interesting to not have sex for a year
that's you're almost in the homestretch
you've only got two more months to go
and I said yeah actually you're right
I've had enough fun I couldn't take a
year off so then I decided to go the
year so I went a full year without sex
and I'll never do it again
yeah and then how did you end the streak
it must have been like a momentous yeah
I was when it rains it pours people just
start appearing out of the bushes yeah
everywhere you go there's a lot of yeah
all sort of men are everywhere you know
how that is well you don't